Odell Beckham jr. is being paid he's
being paid pay that man his money pay
that man his money
what's the matter your keyboard doesn't
work pay that man straight cash sounds
like it's getting close it's not it's
not done yes it's done I got videos of
Sterling Shepherd danced in the Giants
locker room - money money money money
money the summer of Odelle contract is
officially over and this is so pure that
is so crazy for me yeah I go to the
expect net website right the website
where I had everybody put in we had over
400 people guessing when it's gonna
happen right all charted it crashed
haha the website is not working it is
down I literally have no idea who bet
August 27th stupid little Internet I'm
looking online so this is the 27th right
man I can't believe it
highest-paid wide receiver in the NFL
yes I mean well congratulations
congratulations and you know what I
think first thing we have to say is this
to me the number one thing that jumps
out to me about this left go is the
Giants deserve a congratulation do they
I think so tell them what we saw
something this preseason that we've
never seen in the career of NFL and the
history of the league we're a team said
you know you come here and be a good guy
will actually listen to your personal
side and won't throw you out there in
risky situations cuz we understand
you're getting close to being paid and
we'll work with you as long as you work
with us and they actually lived up to
their end of the bargain he was a
professional the team said you know what
we cleared you to play a few weeks ago
we won't throw you out there in
preseason game number three just to see
if you can run the out route still and I
really give the Giants a lot of credit
for doing that and of course Odell
Beckham jr. but I think it's very rare
and this could be a New Age formula we
see going forward Propst Odell for
living up to his into the bargain yes
that does that do you think then that
Gettleman is the one that kind of got
done I think I think Gettleman the
Mehra's Shermer just the whole new
organizational outlook of course mr.
Tish I don't want to leave the Tisch
family out there but I think yes with
Gettleman Shermer together I do think
that's a no-nonsense crew uh and of
course Mara mr. Mara display or you know
putting on display his displeasures with
O'Dell right I'm sick of talking about
it all that I think all those kind of
culminated to where we are now and I'm
just so happy well you haven't heard
numbers yet though right I haven't heard
numbers yet just high-paid highest-paid
five-year contract if you picked August
27th I'm I'm not gonna believe you I'm
gonna show me proof but we will hook up
people so if you're listening you're
like holy crap that's the day I picked
we got to figure out a way to make it
happen I can't believe it crash that's
beyond well I mean is it romantic like
again I'm gonna show my night-night um
nyah tivity here give it a naivete
that's how I was trying to say it I like
once it crashes can't they bring it back
this is do we lose the information that
was on I don't know it's gonna be up to
how many people are contacting this
website to try and get you know the
babies rights yeah yeah I can't believe
we have our Simza left go fantasy draft'
tomorrow night right we are gonna
FaceTime you me and Josh are gonna go to
a bar around here and pick our team for
the golden spleen conference our team is
officially named Odell Rogers I love
that name I was at a fantasy football
draft this weekend and they're like
what's your team name gonna be I was
like Sims came up with Odell Rogers and
he was like they're like does he
understand how football team's name well
yeah it's pretty funny we could really
be three guys two spleens we could do
you have any fantasy football draft
advice for people out there
no I knows one guy let's get he's one
sim sleep oh one guy that's not that
famous or that people aren't that high
on that you are gosh oh man there's
there's there's so many I finished one
that came to your head the first guy
that can die has your Olli sleeper damn
very exclusive slim sweet sleeper
flavor that was too loud Sims sleeper um
the guy that I'm looking for this is
that this is might be way too deep in
the weeds my mind went to number 38 from
the Pittsburgh Steelers the samuel kid
jaylen says jaylen Samuel who was like a
hybrid tight end running back at NC
State I saw him in person I know what
type of player is he was phenomenal in
his last preseason game once again and I
do think he could formulate some type of
role there but I just don't know if it's
gonna be enough numbers there so that's
it's pretty I mean well now you gave me
a crap I mean you could've gave me like
a little warning you're gonna ask me all
right who are you thinking this will
look better than that I mean Anthony
Miller Chicago you know those would be a
guy that I would look at just he's in
the perfect position like there's a 13-3
oh yeah right be Late Late fantasy draft
but Kevin white does look like he's
pretty damn good yeah Allen Robinson he
will be out there I'm not gonna expect
him to be totally who he was the tight
end play would burden their run game
Anthony Miller's gonna find a role and
kind of go unnoticed and under the radar
and that offense knows how to use the
slot receiver I would say that would he
be like the Albert Wilson but another
one is Jaron brown Seattle Seahawks well
hey that's what you asked me now it's a
well general knowledge cometh out of thy
brain ahthe why'd you run bruh because
Doron Brown I think I think he has a
chance to be he's gonna be one of the
three receivers I think on the field
when they go three wives right Baldwin
when he gets back we know I think Tyler
Lockett will be number two and I think
Jaron brown will be number three where
Marshall will have a little his role
will be a little more defined like we
only want you in these situations
man-to-man on the outside back shoulders
Brown yeah I think has the the the eye
of Russell Wilson they've had a little
connection through the preseason and he
can do everything he can go deep he can
run across the middle I think he'll be
sneaky with the with what he can do
pretty while that to Arizona receivers
from last year right really impressing
people John Brown on Baltimore Geron
Brown on Seattle yeah
Cristian Kirk hasn't looked bad either
no he is not okay I was watching the
Colts Niners game yes and some people
hit me up on line and we're like yo why
does
or say were fire referring to quittin
Nelson as something he refers to quit
Nelson now his babyface
so we already know but apparently now he
calls a babyface and he referred to his
babyface like four times right they're
calling him babyface Nelson are we okay
with that I mean he does have kind of
that babyface he and like now it's like
a big Gege face he looks like a big
Gerber baby's like a big Gerber baby
that will just absolutely annihilate you
and pound you to the ground if you
probably crossed the line with that are
we gonna call him babyface III think
it's kind of cool for an offensive line
if your name is wavy face Jim Irsay into
dark your name's babyface and you're
still starting and then you become like
one of the focal guards in football
that's kind of cool they love them and
you saw check Mase and got a five-year
fifty million dollar car I saw it just
as just a little while ago Shaq Mason is
hey that's the going rate for good
guards in football right now and Shaq
double digits yeah eight figures yeah I
mean a good guard is nine to 11 million
dollars and Emily and them really
brought it up yes and I think that it's
gonna be a continuing trend I mean as
you saw in some of my notes this week
you know there's teams I worry about
with their interior offensive line and
it's such a big part because there's
just so many of these special hybrid
defensive linemen in this day and age to
you you better be talented they're your
games it'll be ruined our friend Pacman
Jones gets a contract yeah what up PAC
what do you think what if he would have
called you and said maybe he did what do
you think of Denver what would you know
I just got it I got a text message for
some of his homies for it's just saying
thanks for your support and your help
when you find and I knew before it
became public information that he was
about to sign so I always find that cool
and I think it's a really good spot for
him I really do I do because their
defense it's got a pass rush that's
always gonna take a little pressure away
from the cornerback but their their lack
and I think if you saw my notes that I
wrote you today on the Broncos their
lack of that third solidified corner
right now it's tramaine Brock senior
he's really the other guy right it's
Bradley Roby and Chris Harris jr. with
their base but then when they get into
nickel Chris Harris jr. bumps inside and
they got Jermaine
brach senior their hack man's made for
the salon and a and he's and he's
actually gonna be even better on the
outside for this team because we're
gonna leave Chris Harris jr. in there I
mean that's what he does right so I just
think it gives him a little cushion and
if pachtman plays the way he did last
year he's better than tramaine Brock so
it's gonna help their defense out and I
know that you've really liked their
safeties we're gonna get I do yeah yeah
our big prediction show is Wednesday
yeah I'm thinking about it oh man
wrapping my head around I'm going miles
Gyarados even 70 peace first god this
weekend didn't change it well I said
that two weeks ago I think I'm allowed
to say it yeah that's true I mean I was
I mean watching that game I couldn't
keep my eyes off I know it's it's been
borderline like that every game he just
hasn't had the amount of snaps to show
it yes but it was always even the Giants
game it was running by Eli with a hand
on Eli's he was throwing it and I was
just like oh my gosh I think he bit a
war out solder if that he just do
anything he want
yes he just pushed people I mean he he
literally had Philadelphia going Holly
pulley volley fight I leave he's Jude
Evian he's what we wanted Jadeveon
Clowney to be and he's what Jadeveon
Clowney injury kind of made him more for
us right
I mean he'll never be able to love me
that guy right still amazing but his
ability to come around the edge and Bend
like Garrett is not there anymore
because of that weak me so is who I'm
not gonna give you my defensive MVP okay
but Wednesday you're gonna break down
all the divisions what I'd really like
to do okay is we're gonna pick our
division winners yeah I'm also going
through though all the teams right kind
of the year I'm expecting for everybody
the things that scare me the things that
I don't I'm doing a lot of the work to
look at scheduling yeah and stuff like
that cuz you're gonna look more at
rosters I think I gotta take more
account to scheduling though just wait
you were you're great at that I'm not as
good at that I always evaluate the team
and early season matchups can affect so
much and I sometimes need to do more on
that so we'll do that and then we're
gonna pick the playoffs and we're gonna
pick our awards and all that stuff Super
Bowl all the way through through okay
cool yeah and then uh man some of it
they're really hard yeah I know
really hard like the NFC East took me
like an hour and a half yeah to just sit
there and go you're an idiot I mean the
NFC South yes they got three teams in
the NFC South that can win the Super
Bowl you just spent the afternoon with
al
River on what I had an hour and a half
we had a it's the it's the day where
some of the you know the NBC's the CBS's
the foxes meet with the league office
and you kind of go over some of the new
rules and guidelines that have been
implemented in the offseason it's it's
the league's chance to explain it to the
big TV people the Mike Tirico czar the
world and all that it's got invited I
got invited I don't know how but NBC I
they invited me in there I infiltrated
all right so my par Campion because I am
apparently see this is why I'm worried
about you yeah you're becoming
mainstream media left Co is the one
that's gonna hold this podcast down that
we're on the outside I just don't you
know I'm in the officially officiating
room being the same Kristen's as I
always am making fun of guys that are on
a computer who I don't know what they're
doing there was a guy Greg over there
who they kept telling him to fix stuff
and I was like come on Greg hurry up
holy cow you're slow good job right next
time right I'm doing it right in front
of all the NBC people and Al River Ron
so I'm no different just NBC it was just
NBC as far as the TV now yes right what
did you learn uh well I'll say did they
go do they go so this new head rule and
everybody's like well it certainly was a
lot focused on that and it was a great
teaching moment videos shown there all
right I got number Al River odd number
okay hold on al River on was very good
you're gonna stop Odell Beckham jr.
burst okay I thought you were talking
about numbers maybe for your date on
what the pregnancy date of Odell Beckham
jr. contract the official recorder
breaks don't you don't look at Kim Jon
don't look who is the reporter that you
think broke the numbers just now Oh
Josefina Anderson you are correct yes
five-year extension 65 guarantee okay
okay 95 max deal so five-year extension
65 guaranteed so that's really all I
care about
yeah so that's great 65 guaranteed
nobody's even close to that in the range
that would have been the formula I would
have said from the start like let's
learn a lot of Gera but a lot of the
guarantees all the matters so that's
that's where I look at it and go
I believe and I'm pulling this up as
we're talking right now and I'll make
sure here but I believe that what is
Antonio Browns guarantees weren't even
in that stratosphere I believe do you
know are you there I'm checking it out
I'm gonna beat you
I hope here we go so he's 17 million a
year average and his guaranteed at
signing was get this 19 million Mike
Evans had the largest guarantee up to
this point with 30 8.25 Hopkins 36.5
Jarvis Landry got 34 Julio Jones got 35
5-2 marius 35 so not only is he the
highest-paid right his guaranteed at
signing is double almost every other top
wide receiver in the NFL except for Mike
Evans right double yeah that's amazing
all the other money in there he's
getting it mainly guaranteed and it's an
extension is that what we seeing right
so according to Joey Xena Anders so at
the end of the day it's a six year
ninety eight point five million dollar
deal right that's what a little bit of
clarification here for me and Rappaport
right highest guaranteed ever 65 million
averages 20 million over the first three
years right so it's a front loaded
contract yes it's very rare and he's
into the prime of his career so they
should feel happy about giving him that
money they should and it's gonna give
him I mean I've never seen a front
loaded high guaranteed deal yeah I feel
a little responsible for either you
should we should we've done a lot we've
really fought for him yeah what a great
summer of love co PR for Odell Beckham
yeah so what percentage should I ask him
point zero zero three percent he's got
to give three percent of his agent all
right like what do you think of Ross's
make you feel now that we're going back
to it no no it makes it makes me feel
awesome it was one of the things I
wondered all along what the guarantee
was gonna be because that's the most
important thing and I would think that's
the way the most finagle to lower the
yearly average salary number down to
right so you're doing what is it six
years 98.5 is gonna be total what's that
math real quick as I keep talking six
years 98 right because these getting
eight point
this year is the fifth year option right
right so if it's a five year 90 and a
six year yes it's gonna be what
somewhere around the 16 the 17 range
still is average salary eighteen point
four right so average salary Antonio
Brown still has more except he's got 46
million dollars more guaranteed to him
man than anything else and if Odell
Beckham jr. gets to year four and he's
still one of the best receivers in the
sport time to re-up because that's what
it'll be and he has a chance to do that
I think this is a wise play by him and
the Giants and it works out for
everybody that's the question that I
feel like needs to be asked it's very
okay for us to to go to this for Odell
we call ourselves the players podcast we
care about Odell we think he's that
special right is this a smart move by
the Giants
yeah I'm that's a lot of money it is a
lot of one player you Jedi ran recently
about spending a lot of money in one
position right is this smart for the
Giants I mean his I do think it's smart
for I think it's a once-in-a-generation
'el type player I mean I think he's the
guy that can basically frame your
offense and carry guys like Eli Manning
who are less than average at this point
of their career and he can make them
look like they're average to above
average I do I don't think there's any
problem with this especially when you
break down what it sounds like it's
going to be on average salary that's not
a bad price to pay 17 you mean his
average salary is gonna be a year less
than I mean a million dollars less than
Blake bortles
sign me up deal I'm not trying to even
go down that road I'm gonna saying
that's that's where you've got to think
about it sometimes and then the other
thing that I'll say this that bothered
me is I was hearing that Aaron Donald's
gonna get seventy million guaranteed and
think I mean since when did like the
defensive tackle just has flat-out that
much more worthwhile than the best
receiver in football that's where I was
like a little bit like how could the
guaranteed not be higher in that range
of a Von Miller or somebody like that
for an Adele Beckham junior and I think
this is a game-changing contract for a
lot of receivers going forward yeah what
kind of a ripple effect could this have
I think you're gonna see are we gonna
get out of those 35 million dollar
guarantees with a lot more money per
year and more guarantees is this gonna
be for every position I think to me this
would be the smart way to
even for players to wear I got a break
as for players but for teams yeah I
don't care I don't think it's horrible
for teams in the right the right players
and right situations I don't I don't
think it's horrible hey I know the
Giants are paying 67 million guaranteed
to Eli Manning then I I mean how can you
argue them paying this to this guy mmm I
just mean it could have a ripple effect
I mean we saw rookies like ro Quan Smith
going back and forth over language yes
to me feels very rare well it's rare I
think it could wear I think it can
become a trend setter is I think pliers
could look at it and go screw my overall
number screw my average salary they're
finally realized get me my money early
on and then if I'm ballin the business
is set up to where I'm gonna sit out
training camp and ask for more money and
that and because if I'm not bald and
they're gonna go WOW you know those last
two years and your deal sorry you got to
go we're gonna move on and do something
else so I like it it's it's really good
that the agents and the players are
finally realizing what matters yeah and
this is a great example of this is he
worthy of being the highest-paid Y
receiver do you know why that I know yes
I I'm not I'm not see if there's any
other man Odell Beckham jr. in my life
he's definitely in one of the athletes I
want to meet most and my like my wife
that's the only guy my wife wants to
meet in sports right now she could give
a damn about anybody else but she's like
me oh look school I would have hang out
what time is fashion with him that's
what she says but I truly believe this
and you know I've told someone told you
some of my coach friends have said this
when they've asked me about my thoughts
on a topic I really believed Odell
Beckham jr. is the best receiver I've
ever seen I'm not trying to say that I
have no connection to the guy I'm just
telling you through my true evaluation
I've never seen a guy with the fast
twitch top-end speed route running an
ability to be elusive with the ball in
his hands after that combination all
together and then also be able to high
point and high point and catch 50/50
balls the way he does or one-handed
catches and he's only 511 and that's why
I say he's truly has a chance to be the
greatest ever we're not talking
statistics we're not talking like
overall impact in his
you were saying that if you had to build
a wide receiver yeah the way that you
would want your wide receiver O'Dell
pops yeah I mean I think if you asked me
and go receivers in their prime and you
rank them all time like oh Della's it's
not Johnson Terrell he's in the Randy
Moss like I think Randy Moss is better
in his prime than a Jerry Rice when
Odell gets this contract yeah
what does this do in the Giants locker
room I showed you the video sterling
Sheppard of them going nuts yeah what is
this do turret for a team when a guy
gets a contract like that I just it's a
weight off the team a little bit is it
it is the team's gonna be excited for
him there now no this is our 2018 New
York Giants and here we go and our best
player is pumped and healthy and ready
to go and has no other distractions and
the way I think the Giants treated them
it'll all be positive in the locker room
because he was not excited because the
team's does the the team get excited
because the Giants told Odell to do
something he did it and then he got paid
yeah so the other rest of the team now
is like hey they lived up to their word
right exactly right and that's kind of
huge it's huge in a locker
how much more pressure does this put on
Odell I mean we already know he has
every eyeball on him already right but
does this change his what he has to be
like around the team no he won't
he's got to be more of a leader yeah
well it seems like he's been more of
that guy but you would second everything
I'm about to say whether it's a Justin
Pugh who's told us in the past or other
players we've been around and some of
the coaches and other people I know
beyond the scenes of the New York Giants
I haven't heard a negative thing about
Odell Beckham jr. yet I mean really
haven't it's always like man he's
awesome he loves football and he's
willing to work I mean that's all I ever
hear now I understand he's not like the
perfect person in the world but damn
he's pretty good hmm all right that's
awesome
that's how River on whoa all right yes
wait what did you learn like what did
you learn about the helmet rule I mean
everything you see out there at this
point it's pretty self-evident it's just
basically what the biggest thing I
learned is the number of concussions
when people lower their head and like
hit with
crown of the helmet right that hit right
there is not only concussive the people
that are getting hit it's actually
concussive the people who are hitting
more too and that's what they're trying
to wipe away and this there's been some
ridiculousness here in the early in the
preseason but he tried to say hey that
the rest were getting used to calling
the foul and they're gathering they're
getting used to this speed of the game
as they're calling it all of those
things I'll tell you the thing that was
most impressive to me and I'm gonna
share this it's just how passionate Troy
Vincent who was also in the room is
about defending players and he's truly
worried about players and their safety
and it really showed evident when we
talked about the kickoffs and kickoff
returns left go I mean I'm not trying to
like Troy was legitimately emotional I'm
not gonna say he was gonna cry but it
looked like he might have because he was
like we neglected this play the
concussion rates were too high and we've
gone too long without neglecting it and
when we put all the information
statistics together we'll along with the
same obvious he says we watched it this
year and this is where he got really
passionate and he was just like I mean
we got young guys are killing themselves
in the NFL they're killing themselves on
this play like they're absolutely
killing themselves and changing their
lives because the kickoffs or like was a
certain way that like was it's just it's
all the wedges exactly right but it's
it's it's not only the guys in the wedge
it's the guy trying to break the wedge
it's all of it it's just such a you know
it allows more time for full speed
collisions it and some of my best
stories about guys getting knocked out
and I chuckle you know because I know
they're okay now but they were all kick
off place all of it yeah it's to me it's
really scary because it's what we talked
about it's the Forgotten I don't even
know if it's like it made me more than
40 percent it might be like 60 or 70
percent of the NFL these rosters are
made of guys that will never make enough
money to be generational changing right
toilet Odell Beckham 95 million dollars
65 guaranteed his kids are good their
kids are good yeah this group of guys
that have to do the most dangerous part
running down on kickoffs they're the
ones that also can't protest
when the collective bargaining agreement
comes up right it's this large amount of
very athletic super talented guys that
are probably the heroes of their
hometowns right that are being sent down
not only does no one care about kickoffs
people go to the bathroom during kick
right when you study film you skip
kickoff yes but yet careers were being
lost lives were being changed on this
one play and everyone doesn't want to
change because they don't like change
Gmail changes and people freaked out I
freaked me out
so if how could you take away the
kickoffs if if it's only gonna give me
at most like 11 touchdowns a year from
the whole league and I know it's huge
and special teams is huge but so what
are they doing a change III that's well
you know the rule we have in place this
year to change it right but the kickoff
team they can't run and have them start
you know the 15-yard no contact zone but
I think more more importantly just the
gist I got here with that that whole
meeting is if that play doesn't improve
right it's a one-year trial basis if
that play doesn't improve and the
numbers don't show that they're
lessening the concussions I got the
feeling that the kickoff will be out of
the game next year and sometime here in
the recent future if you could tell from
that ending Joey Vincent just the
higher-ups in the NFL yes
it's it's that concerning to them and it
does sound like that yeah if things
continue to trend in that way with this
high concussion rate in the NFL that
that there that's a definite possibility
as an NFL purist how does that make you
it bothers me a little it does but I can
tell that you're kind of affected by
Troy's emotional I am well I guess what
I gets me - it just hits home with
players and it's also you have to evolve
as a league - and like you said if it's
a play that's only really affecting like
five or six games a year or maybe just
five or six plays a year is it really
worth it to ruin 15 people's brains for
the future that's that's really the
question man yeah that's wild yeah
all right good lunch holy crap yeah -
Wow how about this what someone sent me
a screenshot
expectant I think we might know our
winner for the Odell this is great
everything is happening as we're doing
this show it does not look like it's
been photoshopped I cannot really read
it though I'm gonna arena it looks like
David walleston predicted he was the
only person to say August 27th and he
guessed 12:00 p.m. which is like two
hours ago
from Inglewood Florida like David
walleston to you so David walleston
David Watson if you can confirm this you
will be our first-ever winner
I mean he might be like right on I mean
they might have signed the deal at 12
o'clock I hope you thirty
that's incredible it is darius Teva wall
stood i nailed the contract he just
tweeted at me
August 27th baby O'Dell is poor indeed
dub but he Godey's the the the jiff of
Leonardo DiCaprio dancing in the yeah
what movie is that hey old sport hey old
sport wolf of Wall Street at was wolf of
Wall Street I was thinking you sure that
was it is it look like the other movie
when he was the rich guy Great Gatsby
yes I'm not sure about you David
walleston the confirmation deed um
that's me good job man David walleston
we are gonna reach out to you I'm having
this happened life we are gonna send you
a bunch of Sims and left ghost stuff we
have a bunch to do gear to
congratulations and thank you to
everyone that guessed when was Odell's
contract gonna happen it officially
happened let me get to a few other news
and notes talking about Odell backup
center for the Giants pret Jones traded
to the Vikings you you I'm sure there's
a lot of people going is Brett Jones
good is Brett Jones good Brett Jones is
a capable starting type of center in
football the veggies need them there bro
Vikings have issues right now but yes I
mean I don't you know they're they're
injured in their interior 3 right they
had the one guy retire elf line I don't
think is still back one of them just
came back to practice so yeah I think
they're just thin at the position
overall it's a smart move and it's a
good backup yeah OB melon Fon woo yeah
released by the Raider right this is a
guy that you were very high on coming
out of UConn for the draft right what
was your reaction
I guess I was shocked a little just the
fact that they abandoned ship so early I
mean it's only a second training camp
but he I don't know what to expect of
them yeah we haven't really got to
evaluate him I when I'm claimed on
waivers yes
he's on the injured reserve Raiders now
so he's on the IR right so I don't know
it's it's hard for me to evaluate I know
Gruden with young guys he ain't got time
for it if you can't get out there and
produce and help out the team and that's
kind of what we've seen to his team be
so far well yeah but that's kind of a
Gruden thing though Gruden is yeah he
just has no time for the young guy who
can't contribute that's why I mean III
think it's interesting if you just look
at his offseason in general it's a lot
of veteran players to fill holes
the Raiders just tradable Ryan Switzer
to the Steelers yeah I know is that for
the Raiders
the Steelers don't have a third receiver
you know or they're looking for that
slot type guy they don't have it Justin
hunters kind of been that he's the guy
on the outside right and then they can
do juju and Antonia Rodgers is hurt yes
Eli Rogers right he's been hurt since
Bennet he tore his ACL in the divisional
playoff game last year I don't think
James Washington can be that guy so yeah
I think you know who else could be who
was a little popping on on film and I'll
get there in a second but the Ryan
Switzer like if they want to go Antonio
Brown outside and juju Smith juju Smith
Shuster outside who's they have in the
roster that's a true slot guy I think
that's what they gotta be thinking yeah
because like Washington's not that guy
Justin hunters more of an outside guy
like you saw in the game this weekend
101 he's gonna run by you and score a
touchdown the other guy that pops and
you probably saw it on my is the Griffey
kid tre Griffey oh yeah
tre Griffey is that tre gift Griffey
looks good might have a role he I mean
he's he can contribute to that football
team in all capacities they probably
don't trust them to be the total slot
guy yet but I was impressed of what I've
seen from him mmm
alright so I got a few other news notes
I want to get to yeah Jared Goff is not
gonna play a snap this preseason
kneeler neither is Gurley Sean McVeigh
played zero starters the entire
preseason
Matt Nagy played zero starters for week
three of the preseason yeah week three
is supposed to be where all the starters
are playing I got your news and notes
here but are we seeing a change in NFL
preseason as well I mean I think that
it's also how is that possible yeah I
think that did you not play anything
right well the day and age of like Oh
preseason game number three is the dress
rehearsal that's over this weekend
solidified that it's it's just not some
teams don't care hey Aaron Rodgers
didn't play you know there's a lot of
other guys at it but Ezekiel Elliott
hasn't played I mean you go down the
list who whatever it is you know the
Raiders they only sent their guys out
there for one series and preseason game
three well big dress rehearsal for one
drive so I think we've gotten to the
time and day in the sport where as we
talked a little bit about last week with
like my dad had the games just bigger
and faster and more physical than ever
that teams are willing to maybe not
function or execute on its highest level
week one to four not having to deal with
that risk of losing a guy that can
change your season now Jared Goff I'm
gonna be interested to see where this
goes with this is it I guess my question
is like do you think when you were gonna
be starting do you I know having any
reps well I know when I was and tooth
when I got reps I was better 2006 the
year I lost my spleen Gruden didn't
really play us much in the preseason cuz
we were a very top-heavy team and I
think he was very worried that if we
lost a few starters that we'd be screwed
and I know that when I got into week one
I wasn't the same Chris Sims that I
needed to be everything was moving too
fast I was not as comfortable I can
still remember Paul Hackett my
quarterback coach gone you need reps in
the preseason like this is just that's
the kind of guy you want when the rams
play the Raiders in week one you could
see the Rams maybe starting a little
slow I definitely can out of the fact
that Jon Gruden is gonna get ready to
unveil the kitchen sink on them for a
week one of me he still did nothing last
week even with the starters in like they
look pretty good they learn a teacher
Larry Cooper so now the Rams the good
thing they have in their advantage is
you know the Raiders defense is
certainly not the Steel Curtain or the
Raiders of the 70s on defense so they
and the Cardinals the next week to where
it's not too overwhelmingly talented
football teams like the Rams are gonna
be the more talented football team on
the field and both of those matchups man
and they got a guy like Todd Gurley now
girl he's a guy that does not need reps
I mean he's like an Ezekiel Elliott or
some of the freak running backs of the
Adrian Peterson's of old they don't need
it no I mean they're they're a different
cut of cloth than the rest of us Jalen
Ramsey just tweeted it's going to be a
show very soon
hashtag Batman vs. the Joker who's
Batman in Odell versus Ramsey and I was
the Joker
I guess Odell's Batman huh it seems like
it right he's Bruce Wayne now so I guess
up that games gonna be so good I'm so
glad he got paid I do think this is
again though another case of what we
talked about last week two left go where
I know Dez Bryant thinks I'm not for the
players getting paid but here's another
to skirt like Odell Beckham jr. is not
22 times greater than Dez Bryant you
know what I mean it's at the stats
without that's that's the other thing
too like it's just the low-level guys
have to start getting I think a little
more guarantee there's no middle class
there's no middle class exactly right
it's rich and fight for your life gets
either get like 1.5 million or 95 yes
we're still waiting on Aaron Donald
we're still waiting on Khalil Mac
Marquis Lee out for the season and after
his knee injury yeah it was actually
like bortles best throw the game - yeah
I got a nice little crossing route but
you still think they're gonna be good
with Dede Westbrook Kealing Cole or is
this like now a weaker wide receiving
core
marques Lee was you know he's a really
good football player he's not like a
number one superstar of receiver right
marquise Lee I looked at him as just
going he's a number two that's really
good he can do everything he can catch a
screen and make something happen
he can run nice routes and run the short
routes that you need with crispness and
detail and he also had enough speed to
just be people straight away but yes
good Lefko they're receiving core is is
very good still I mean whether you want
to go with Kiel and Cole Westbrook like
you said Donte Moncrief is still there
they got you know two running backs that
can catch the ball well out of the
backfield I mean you know in Yeldon and
grand I'm not even counting for me
who also catches the ball well too so I
don't think it's gonna be like a huge
blow to their overall team Jalen Ramsey
on the hit said you can't be mad at the
safety guy be mad at the NFL but that is
how the rule is people are scared to
tackle normal because I guess they don't
want to do helmet to helmet and get
flagged right you were just in a meeting
with Al River yeah and this guy was just
on one of the clips i watch for bad hit
Kazee yes but in terms of do you agree
with Jalen Ramsey saying that the helmet
to helmet rule is causing people to go
low which is causing more me well yeah I
mean yes we know this I mean remember
Larry Fitzgerald was telling people I'll
pay the fine just hit me in the head
please I don't want to be hitting the
knees so yes I would say this is part of
the problem and part of the issue I
would also say this though and again
this is really hard for a defensive
player and I'm not trying to like say
you can totally avoid this but he did
drop his head and like lost where he was
going at and he didn't have to go right
at his knee joint like if you're looking
you can hit somebody in the thigh and do
that but no this is one of the
unfortunate intended cons on intended
consequences of the new rule man I was
nasty it was gross yeah I can't even
watch it alright we have a lot of really
good notes from you this week but I'm
gonna start off with a text message that
you sent me
damn rg3 looks better than a lot of
starters he can still be a superstar he
held it together yeah you also texted me
saying that NFL teams would be stupid
not to trade for rg3 right break it down
yeah I mean at first I I think there's
got to be a market for some of these
backup quarterbacks this year you know I
just look at let's just say Teddy okay
we talked about him rg3 there's somebody
else in the mix that I'm blanking out
with right now but I think there's a
number of teams that are taking a very
big risk with their backup quarterback
situation Jacksonville is one of them
okay I mean okay that's one of them
Seattle Seahawks are another one the Los
Angeles Rams I mean if you watch Sean
Mannion
I mean if golf goes down I don't I don't
know it's really scary
Denver Broncos Chad Kelly's been really
good I'm just saying he's raw and he's
young I don't know if you want to trust
him a day last year was the perfect
example of why backup quarterback
surgeon exactly right Rodgers went down
the team imploded yes whence went down
the team sustained right rg3 has
tremendous he still has you you know me
I I don't like rg3 I think he screwed
over the Shanahan family I think we all
know he did he was a baby he was
privileged brought it on that on the
whiteboard right but I'm not gonna sit
here and just say he's no good because
the film tells me he's really damn good
and his decision-making has been top
notch his throwing has been top notch I
mean it's a perfect spiral on the screws
every time and did you see that
[ __ ] run last week cuz it
straight away race now Maher has more
side to side but I felt like RG three
took off a few times the other night was
like I thought it was the Mark III well
I think he was like it did you mother
yeah I think he wasn't one to run he's
probably saying like did you
[ __ ] forget that I can run to
that I was like yeah four by 100 right
in Texas yeah right so he has been one
of the gems of the preseason and I even
the Carolina Panthers mmm I mean you
guys that you're gonna go with Blake I
mean guilt Garrett Gilbert you gonna go
with one of them if we will do those
that Heinicke as they're back then yeah
right yeah that's bad
yes so you and you think that RG three
is better the dollars do you think RG
three is better the number of starters
like when I was watching Miami Baltimore
I texted this Jays more talent than Ryan
RG three looked more impressive than
Ryan Tannehill greed RG three has the
type of talent to be one of the five
best quarterbacks in football Ryan
Tannehill will never be one of the top
five quarterbacks in football I'm not
trying to say that to be mean to Brian
Tannehill he's good and he can lead them
to the playoffs and a Super Bowl I truly
believe that but RG three has a special
skill set he really does he's got a
special arm he can launch it he can
throw it with touch and it's really
about the off the field how he conducts
himself around the team and the coaches
that's really the biggest unanswered
question about nuru
he held it together yeah does that mean
I feel like most guys that go down his
lane end up Ryan Lee fish Johnny Manziel
ish right where it's just the wheels
fall off for two or three years and
everybody goes man I don't know we can
take a chance on you again you went down
to crazyville for a few weeks yeah you
know a few how do you think he turned it
around uh I think that he loves the
sport and I think he probably realized
that he had to become a little bit more
humble and that he left his Lane in
Washington in a few other places and I
think he's realized that he's got to
have a new approach like he does
I am impressed like I said not the
biggest fan of the person but I'm not
gonna hate on the guy's ability and
that's why I respect you because you can
self Scout and whatever they show in the
film is how you're gonna judge it
another text you sent me was because I
texted you man Kenyan Drake looks
amazing yeah oh yeah what did you say
back is that what I said I said he's
better than Alvin he has more physical
ability than alvin kamara right he said
Kenyan Drake has more raw ability than
Alvin Kamara he does and I didn't
respond you didn't I know cuz I was like
that's a fire tag i Kenyan Drake is a
special player as is Alvin Kamara but
Drake you know he's he's in between the
tackles workhorse who can run through
arm tackles just like an Alma Kamara I'm
not trying to say he can't do anything
like that either
but just like Alvin Kamara too he
catches a screen watch out he gets out
on the edge like he did the other night
watch out because 60 70 what'd you learn
a lot from doing fantasy traps as you
see the way that people are slightly
feels to say well no here's the thing
the way that you do a fantasy draft is
you see the players that people want
right and what happens is is like
everybody wants alvin kamara
like even the top of the giraffe people
are like man I I know I should take
David Johnson but that alvin kamara he's
fun I want him on my team right people
that take Kenyan Drake like Dennis the
guy I was in the show on the writer for
gridiron heights he's like I took Calvin
Kenyan Drake in the third round and I
didn't even really want to like there's
like this I'm taking him here but I
don't really want them right and you're
here telling me that he's more you know
as more raw
building Kamara he does I mean there's a
reason I thought that he had a chance to
be the Rookie of the Year a few years
back he does have a fumbling issue
that's gonna be really one of the
biggest things we have to watch it was
that Alabama its surface a little last
year but you know yeah I think it's it's
the modern-day running back but what
still says reports that he's gonna split
carries with Frank Gore with Adam GaSe
yeah okay great I could just tell you
Frank Gore ain't gonna look like Kenyan
Drake when he runs through that first
hole Frank Gore was really good but he
can't do the things Kenyan Drake good
what about an Adam GaSe offense I think
I think it should really suit him well I
do I think he's got a plenty of ways to
throw to the ball out of the backfield
and feature little specific schematics
on how to get him the ball alright we
did my right was the last week he didn't
he catch a wheel route out of the
backfield I got so many damn games and
highlights in my head I thought KJ
caught a like a 30-yard kind of good
right okay I know I can't I got one on
stir catch a 30-yard run in a 30-yard
reception so that's what I mean he's
he's he's like an album Kamara except I
think he's a hair stronger and a hair
straight away faster and I really just
fum Camaros awesome right all right
let's do some game notes we're gonna
start with the Thursday game Browns
Eagles up well scare did you just Bart
Burt a burp get into the microphone oh
well the fans want to hear it they want
it to be real
miles Garrett is unbelievable he really
is one guy though that you said was not
that unbelievable was Jamie Collins yeah
maybe the the one face that everyone
kind of knew after the trade right you
wrote Jamie Collins is definitely not
100% running full speed and later you
added Jimmy Collins is not good what's
happening well I I just feel like I had
thought about Bill Belichick right off
the bat yes he's certainly not running
to full speed and we saw that a little
bit with the interception he had during
the game remember the interception he
caught on nick foles yes he tries to run
across the field I mean in the offensive
linemen around that the world where
Jamie vic falls just like threw it right
to his chest i was right i know he never
saw him which tells you that the game is
going faster
yes I just saw too many undisciplined
plays where okay he's always been like
that too
agree but and year and sometimes you're
gonna mess up I get all that but he used
to have the physical explosion to to go
okay I was supposed to be in the C gap
but I'm in the B gap and Dan there goes
the running back in my gap I'll just
blow the lineman up and push him into
the gap and we'll figure out a way to
get it done or or I'll just use my speed
and run through the B gap and get them
running back just as he's getting to the
C gap that's look at the crap he used to
pull pull off right yeah but with him
not moving in that way right now
yes he's he's going through the B gap
and he's getting through there and the
guys already through the C gap and it's
a it's a 20 yard run and it's just
things like that that concerned me a
little bit but with his play and they
have other good linebackers yeah you
really do like the other two you like
Christian Kirk and Michael Kendricks
along I think it's the two best I don't
really understand the Schobert thing I'm
sure I looked it up yeah so this is how
dumb tackles are yeah three leaders in
the NFL last year in tackles right or
Joe Schobert yeah other Cleveland Browns
Blake Martinez of the Green Bay Packers
and Preston brown who's now on the
Bengal right I mean it goes back to our
old who was our conversation right love
camembert's in a trick willis the white
linebacker from no wisconsin yeah I know
the one that retired and everyone says
he was amazing he had he had 18 tackles
against the Rams he led the NFL that
week in tackles it was so amazing and
I'm not sitting here trying to make fun
at anybody or anything Chris Chris
Borland thank you very much
but like of the 18 tackles that week I
remember we talked about it like 16 of
them were like 12 yards down the field
like he had already run through the line
of scrimmage and oh wow you got a tackle
great you were supposed to make the
tackle three yards passing line of
scrimmage you're a linebacker that's
where you play you're chasing him and
making the tackle so yeah yes I don't
see it with Schobert I don't know I do
like Hendrix and Kirk Steele Kirksey for
sure and Kendricks yeah Kirk C's become
one of the leaders on the team when you
watch hard knocks easy no boy that and
he should be I mean he's he's a plier
man he really is he's great on all three
downs other just little notes and then
we're gonna go to the other big topic
from this game other notes you wrote
David and joke who has a chance to be
special yes you wrote that Baker
Mayfield never loses control the ball
such a quality thrower yeah you wrote
that Caleb Brantley pops for the Browns
he really does on the Eagle side you
think that Josh sweat could be special
but all the knee holdup yeah you wrote
that Sydney Jones versus Avante Maddox
will be entertaining so you're telling
me that the former could be first-round
pick is battling with a guy they got
taking like the fourth round it seems
like Sydney's got the edge right now
but I like Avante man I think that
Sydney is not the guy he was yet you
know what I mean so yeah I think when I
look at Maddox and I look at the play on
the field I think it's very close and I
think Maddox has maybe another gear
right now that Sydney Jones can't hit
because of that Achilles and still not
you know being the guy he once was I do
I think that'll be interesting to watch
as we go along you also wrote that
DeAndre Carter is the most explosive
wide receiver on the field for the
Eagles yes number two he does pop every
time I turn on the game just now your
knee some of your good guys aren't out
there but he's still out of the group
that you've had out there the last two
games yes he's he's the guy he's the guy
when I turn on the film I go damn who is
that to two yards in front of everybody
else getting off the ball all what it's
the aundrea goodness yeah
the other tho thing that you wrote down
that we need to talk about is this nick
foles
know you wrote even the completed passes
are off target doesn't give wide
receiver any chance for yards after
catch foals is a step slow for modern
NFL pocket movement is not up to par
with good quarterbacks his first
interception was worse than rookie
second interception was rookie [ __ ]
again yeah how is the guy that tore up
the Vikings and tore up the Patriots
looking this bad in the preseason it is
a little you know I'm dumbfounded to to
that drastic that polar-opposite really
right his throwing mechanics look a
little off in general to me like he's
leaning forward I wish I could
demonstrate a little bit but none of the
nothing's crisp out of his hands I mean
I know you're watching you see every
throws got semi wobble on it it's a
slant route oh the receiver caught it
but he had a fall down right or it was a
foot behind him
he couldn't run full speed to actually
make something have every throw his
question every throw was questionable
and uh I I don't have it
you do have years where you're better or
worse I just don't know if he's just not
a starting NFL quarterback I think
that's what we're kind of seeing right
it's crazy to say that Nick Foles is not
a starting NFL quarterback when I just
watched him do that - I know I just
think there's a there's a different
there's a different feel of being the
guy and having to be the guy from day
one and training kid but if you could be
the guy of the Super Bowl then you can
be it in week I the priest I get that I
know but it's there is something to it
like I get it he should be totally free
but again you know there was a working
period he got to to get to be that guy
with the New England Patriots and the
other the rest of the team was way ahead
of them and it afford him the luxury to
kind of catch up and right now they need
him to be the forerunner I guess is what
I'm trying to say the guy that say hey
vite eyes not real good right now things
like this are not perfect we need you to
make some plays right now - Karras
that's what Carson Wentz did latch do
you think because Doug Peterson kind of
flipped out on a reporter cuz he asked
when Carson was gonna be cleared do you
think the way Foles has looked is the
reason Doug Peterson snapped because
maybe he's a little stressed out because
he's seeing what's happening right now
yes I don't think it's adding to it
people realize if you look at the first
14 weeks of the Eagles they were not
that great of a team
Carson Wentz was that special you gotta
say it man because I say and people
think I'm just a little that's why my
Irish Eagles the Eagles roster yeah okay
they don't have LeGarrette Blount so
it's gonna be a little bit different
right now I look at their wide receivers
and it's okay to say that it is a big
step down in my mind between Torrey
Smith to Mike Wallace right now yeah
they're gonna need more the other guys
yeah I think it's also a step back from
trey Burton to Dallas Gadar yeah just in
terms of athlete yes he's a longer
stroke guy yes I don't know what I'm
getting out of Darren Sproles this point
and the Eagles offensive line other than
Jason Peters was pretty healthy the
whole year yeah and from what I saw with
Holly Pugh leave a levite I
they don't have Jason Peters they could
really be in trouble defensively
Nigel Bradham suspended for the first
game against Atlanta the defensive line
tipped Tammy Jernigan is banged up and
Michael Bennett and hole OD now to have
it looked that great thus far right and
the Senate couldn't even start I mean
not Bennet I mean they I knew got nada
BIOS is starting right but I look at
this team and I go yes they overcame a
lot of injuries but they were
historically successful on third and
fourth down last year right to the point
we have never seen it before we're
talking like 75% like six succession or
like third in law 1414 one no 11 is his
number 11 Carson Wentz he was incredible
he was the best third down quarterback
in the sport how many times have we sit
here at bleacher report watch TVs and go
holy crap broke that tackle and made
that throw or he broke that tackle and
made that run yes those statistics
regress to the mean I will guarantee you
that the Eagles will not be as good at
third down and fourth down as they were
last year
and if they don't have a special guy in
there like Carson Wentz to make up for
everything then they're just not that
good of a football team they're probably
a nine and seven ten and six football
team and if Carson Wentz not out there
there are seven and nine football team
that's just the reality of this Eagles
team sure so I think that's why Doug's
hit a little stressed out I think you're
totally right he's stressed out because
the offense isn't doing good he's got
the Super Bowl MVP who's playing like a
true backup and he's got people asking
him every day about Carson Wentz and of
course if Carson Wentz was cleared he's
gonna tell you he's cleared it right
away he's not trying to hide it so he's
just it's getting to that time of the
year where stress levels are getting up
for head coaches because they got to
figure out rosters they're cutting
players and their minds are already
going to week one regular season right
now it's like oh gosh screw preseason
game number four all he's thinking about
is he just watched Atlanta film probably
right before that was like damn they're
good they're just as fast as last year
and more dangerous and we've looked like
crap I'm making this prediction now
Alana's gonna win yes yeah Atlanta's
could have beat Philadelphia to open the
season the
be super motivated after they went to
Philadelphia and really had the Eagles
yeah they were the better team for like
three oh so no I'm very much I've
actually been thinking about it too and
I already have on the record okay so if
you pick them you're just following me
I'm gonna I'm also thinking about the
Patriots collapsing to the Chiefs last
year in the first game right and I'm
like I could totally see that yeah it
happens it's human I mean the banners I
think Atlanta's can have a very good
year yeah well Alana's calls Falcons
haters but they're the damn game let's
go to Panthers Patriots we're not gonna
get to all the news and notes but I'm
gonna get to the big one let's start off
with the Panthers big one was this
Carolina offense has a totally different
feel than any other year with Cam Newton
during this era more formations more
traditional running game Cam Newton
looks really good yes I want to hate on
North turn
I'm just gonna say this everybody I'm
still annoyed that Norv Turner that Mike
Zimmer went in and North Turner's
offense and says your offense sucks
you're ranked 32nd the NFL and Norv
Turner said I quit yeah whoo and he's
been given a free pass no one remembers
it yeah if any other player quit on a
team they'd call him an absolute like
they called Martellus Bennett a quitter
in Green Bay they hate him right but
North Turner's off the hook right and I
think that his offense wasn't that great
anyway I think it's kind of old it's
it's we still four teams 20 years ago
with the Cowboys right 20 years ago
almost 30 years ago at this point but
what are you noticing that that's
different
let's go positive after my little hate
rain all right yes let's let's just
click all right the Cowboys is awesome
so most the Chargers when he was there
with LaDainian Tomlinson so let's just
do a listen I got away with that whole
thing too and I also get annoyed that no
words got his whole family down there as
the offensive coordinator League problem
it's not necessarily personal to norv
but I mean they want to wonder why
there's minority issues in the league
and all that's because every coordinator
and head coach has their like seven
levels of their family tree on the
roster so but the Phil
the film is basically this the array of
formations and concepts and screens and
the different ways to run the football
it's no longer a college type offense
with a few professional drop back pass
game concepts it is a true NFL drop back
pass game there's lots of screens
there's pulling guards and downhill run
game and cam is not just sitting there
like early in the preseason he was a
little bit like in his old way of like
let me hold the ball and wait for the
guy to be thirty yards down the field
and I'll rifle it in there
I do see nor of is teaching him to be a
quarterback teaching him when de you
know know when to hold them and when to
fold them okay it's covered it's not
there let's not take the extra three
hitches and wait for him to come open
just throw it underneath that tres to
have a different appearance even though
it's preseason yeah I do the offense
looks dramatically different it really
does and they got you know they got
something going because with our man
Curtis Samuel jump it on in the show
last week to show me okay here comes
Kurt of Samuel and DJ more DJ more and
Longinus look very good in Olsen's
healthy McAfee and McCaffrey I start to
go damn there quietly getting like what
we always talked about with the good
offenses right I am over Caffrey and
everyone on my Fender stand that do you
think he can last the whole year as a
primary guy you know I always thought in
college he would die out I was a good
kid to this downhill Stanford run game
there's no way but the little the little
[ __ ] quick and he knows how to just
get out of way from the huge car crashes
so I'm gonna say yes yeah you wrote you
ended your Carolina take with [ __ ] the
NFC is good Carolina Panthers I mean the
NFC South I have a hard time believing
the Carolina Panthers are gonna be good
like they lost all those offensive
linemen I know and they look pretty damn
good once they got in there I'm gonna
I'm not gonna lie when I I think one of
the things I wrote in my notes is you
know some of these guys are better than
I gave credit for and again this is
always the hardest thing about our job
it's the second tier offensive linemen
that we don't get to see a lot of yes
and you think a guy goes down and you go
oh damn he's he's this guy backing up so
a little better than I thought
like Taylor mote on the kid they drafted
a few years ago remember him yeah uh he
he's doing a pretty good damn good job
you know they got the sigh rolls kid in
there who's been around the league a
little bit of different places did okay
like Holly pulley Valley vitai we got
great in the rest of the season and then
he's looked awful this for our Patriots
notes explain this to me
yeah rope Patriots offense ran why stick
smoke I can't believe it and you put in
three exclamation points yes what does
that mean because this is another thing
of the NFL doesn't pay attention to what
New England does okay or doesn't do New
England doesn't like New England doesn't
have a three-step drop back pass game
they don't do it really like I bet you
can count on one hand the amount of
times that Tom Brady took a three-step
drop and threw a slant route last year
they don't do it they don't do what do
they do
they don't do if they do a slant or
something like that you're gonna see the
old play action pass and he's gonna come
up and it's not a three-step it's more
of a five to eight steps land where he's
gonna come across the middle through
slants not really know if you really
will as the year goes on I'll show you
why stick is basically like the five
yard out route from the tight end it's
to me one of the Dumber plays in all of
football it's like it's a constant the
risk/reward is just not what like some
of these West Coast coaches think you
know it's the kind of place like we're
Brian Hoyer through the pick sixes on
last year further when he was playing
for the 49ers there's a bunch of other
number ones oh let me let me drop back
three steps and stare at the big freakin
tight end who's next to the awesome
defense end and they shall Bowl I'm back
in the Telus myths of the world are all
there and let me real quick look at them
and then rifle a ball and do them and do
a crowd of people oh we got four yards I
threw the perfect throw vervoids it's
the dumbest crap ever New England
doesn't do that [ __ ] it's like the same
thing with New England on the goal line
I wanted to write for Carolina their
goal line stave drove down the field the
first drive of the game they're pulling
guards on the one-yard line
New England doesn't pull guards on the
one-yard line cuz they're not gonna let
great defensive tackles replace the
pulling guard and then ruin the play
from behind it's just sometimes you go
just there may also do not throw the
ball high at the goal line
exactly all we
through a low in the front high in the
back yes there that's what I just don't
know as a moral watching the Patriots
sometimes like those are things what
they're looking at
see it's Brady no no no no no they're
looking at scheme and they're looking at
bigger picture and they're missing the
details you know what book I just
started reading the the the score takes
care of itself
right right right Bill Walsh is so
freaking meticulous that it's almost not
a good read yeah because he's so
detailed to everything he literally sat
down the secretaries with how they're
supposed to answer the phones
hello you've called the same because
that detail needed to be ironed out and
he has no patience Bill Belichick is the
same way and it's the details that
separate you the fact that I didn't
realize and I don't think a lot of
people realize that the Patriots don't
run slants I feel like my entire life
I've watched Edelman and Amendola oh
yeah because you've seen them catch
those short footballs but that what
Brady is doing more times than not is
looking at a five-step concept to his
left right
maybe Gronkowski on a 12-yard out route
with Phillip Dorsett on the outside
running a go route or a post route over
the top he gives it a quick look and
goes oh it's not there and then you have
the Edelman's of the a mandalas who are
like running jerk routes or option
routes and their reenact are a slam but
it's a late developed it's a late right
it's like take your time Tom's not gonna
get there right away
yeah let the linebacker think you might
sit there and then he's gonna come to
you and as soon as he comes to you fly
across his face and run a shallow cross
on Tom's gonna hit you and you're gonna
run for 20 more years so when you saw
the why stick smoke I couldn't believe
it and I it almost it was not a good
play I almost got intercepted and I
wanted to be like I've I bet you Tom
watched film the next day and said don't
call that play ever again don't call it
like I don't want to deal with it did
you rewind a lot I did I rewound it a
few times because they don't do that or
double commands and so not now but text
them what just feel like I can't believe
you ran why stick smoke oh you're
talking about Josh McKenna I think I'm a
tower Josh will be like I cannot believe
and I'd be curious like if he responds
to you like has he
done it before well I remember in one of
my meetings in Denver we call to slant
New England calls two slants tosser
right first glance either slide no like
the same two slants from the same the
the back receiver almost replaced right
or used exactly right so it's like that
right and I know Brady threw an
interception on it early in his career
and he hates me hates that he hates so
fun I remember McDaniels when I was in
Denver like here's tosser I don't call
him much Tom hated this play he threw a
pick on it you know I mean it's hard
tom has a play that he kind of got a bad
taste of his mouth early on and he just
doesn't want the rest of his career yeah
it's it's again it's a risk/reward thing
to to where you know you're not really
getting a chance to look over the
defenses you're kind of throwing it
blind exactly how many times have you
seen like those good slot guys who are
they're covering the inside slant and
they see the eyes go to the outside and
they drop off and get underneath the
outside slam right so those are the
things that's why why we put Tom in that
position let Tom drop back and he'll
read it out and he's gonna find the
right guy so don't make him have to make
this quick no-nonsense decision the only
other Patriots nugget that I mean
there's a lot that I wrote down but one
was Dante Howard Hightower excuse me
Dante Hightower doesn't look the same
his legs and explosion do not look good
yeah now that's upsetting it is
upsetting because I do like him and
maybe it'll come around again he's
another guy that's been out of football
here for a little bit but yeah I just
did not see the same explosive
sledgehammer type of guy that I've seen
you know in years past from him you know
one more that I just have to bring up
with the Danny Shelton thing real quick
you said that Danny Shelton looks so
much better versus the past and the run
this is why they got him to push the
pocket I really think it is I mean run
game he's not what you would think it's
not like Oh surprising you're not
running the ball on New England with
Danny Shelton there I want to be like no
you're gonna run it for like three or
four yards if he's there but the past
game what that's been on what he's been
doing this preseason and that's what I
really think that's why Bill got him I
really do we've always talked about them
so you think a lot of people think he's
gonna be out on the third down you're
like no he might only be in on here
exactly right really exactly what is so
special about his pass rush he just got
he's got a pretty good initial explosion
to go straight ahead and
when he catches that guard in the past
set to take a step back it's just too
much momentum for them to stop right off
the bat and he gets his hands underneath
your breasts or your pectorals and these
guys are like oh gosh and they can't
stop themselves speaking of I saw a clip
of Gino Atkins lifting Vladimir Ducasse
off the ground his feet were off the
ground
I am Bengals beat the crap out of the
bills we were texting during the game
did you Josh Allen need to get the ball
out sooner or did he just not have any
time at all I'll watch the film but no I
mean those were like those were like it
doesn't I don't care
he got sacked five times right I think I
thought like for them no quarterback in
football would have got out of that and
there was one that maybe he could have
got out of his hand
yeah but Geno Andrew Billings in them a
few times are all awesome I mean it was
like party at the quarterback meet you
there look I loved Andrew Billings in
the trash yeah just because he was built
exactly like Geno right right that they
told the story yesterday Charles Davis
it was one of my favorites that he broke
like the lifting records of Mark Henry
him and Geno I mean that's proud that is
probably I think Carl Lawson is special
he is special
it's John Ross had a good play John Ross
had a good play man if they can get that
out of John Ross know you know watch out
especially right after like last week
when I travel in Josh Allen scares me
what doesn't mean just like carson wentz
willingness to take physical condom he
was banging off I mean go down he's got
a D he's got a three technique defensive
tackle hanging on his back and he's
still standing up like and then the guy
falls off him and almost falls and Clips
his knee and hurts somebody still can
stay up cuz he's be strong right and
it's always those guys I feel the same
way with Lamar Jackson you've got to
know we're gonna kill himself
Josh you just got to go down sometimes
you got to realize this is not you know
Wyoming and you're not playing North
Dakota State with like a defensive
tackle who's 275 pounds the guys that
are 275 pounds now our linebackers and
defense and they're a lot faster and
stronger and the D tackles are 320 and
you just can't do it and if you fight
that that hamstring more like pops ring
or ACL Zanda go Giants Jets yeah you
wrote every ball that darn
throws it barely makes it to the target
wide receiver always has to go down to
get it just not a lot of impressive in
the pocket passes yet yeah I watched the
game and I thought he played pretty well
yeah he just gave me four heart attacks
with balls like barely getting over a
coroner's hand right I think he's great
moving in the pocket I think he really
does protect the ball does but those
outside throw scare me to death and I
also don't think Robbie Anderson's gonna
be a factor that doesn't cease and
Arnold starts I don't see Robbie
Anderson being a big factor i I don't
know either you're right and you know
I'm not so sure that they'd they'd like
they're not gonna be desperate without
them they're kind of sneaky good a tight
end a wide receiver but yeah I would say
I've seen everything I've wanted to see
from Sam Donald except for that the
ability I have not had that in the
pocket five or six throws ten throws
whatever it may be like I've seen Rosen
or may feel the Allen go where I've just
been like man whoa what a throw that was
great now he's made good throws his his
feet and ability to escape the pocket
and throw on the run or off still
phenomenal but yeah I mean we feel
comfortable starting in week one I would
me too yeah I would he just don't those
outs yeah I know cuz they're gonna go to
the house and he can fix it like I broke
it down and really watched him
mechanically and was like glass cam yeah
I did what did you he's got to learn to
get like his back foot underneath him
right what's on doing so he gets it
sometimes he doesn't take that little
hitch gather step and he tries to just
let his foot hit and he just tries to
throw it up step throw instead of step
step gather gather like the Aaron
Rodgers crow hop where again like I'm up
I'm standing I don't care right now but
yes like I'm a lefty throwing to you
yeah and I want my left leg to be
underneath my left shoulder it's my
position of power right yeah you don't
want it to be out here right I mean
where's tower is when it gets out there
at times and it compromises it and how
can you throw the ball up with
trajectory too if your legs out here
like this right I mean I know you don't
play golf a lot or whatever but if
you're gonna drive a ball and
trying to hit it 300 our baseball oh
yeah exactly right you're not gonna put
your back foot way outside your shoulder
and then go I'm still gonna be as
powerful you know cement I'm pretty damn
good at with football I know what you're
talking was underneath you it was you
like the Jets defense you were very
impressed with the Giants run defense do
you think it could be top five yeah the
big thing though that I take away was
your takes on the Giants offense you say
the Giants offense is good they're gonna
drive down field a lot say Quan and
Odell don't make incredible plays though
can the Giants score touchdowns because
you wrote Manning is not capable of
making big-time throws or moving like
other good quarterbacks right you did
say though that the play-action crossers
is a staple of the Giants offense and
you think the Giants had the perfect
team to do that with O'Dell yeah Ingram
and Sterling shepper and sacrum you like
that Eli was aggressive he's maybe not
like even the throw to the deep throws
were a little short right but he was
still throwing them he was coming out
firing that's the first thing I feel
like the last few years we've got an Eli
of I'll just check it down or oh I'm
gonna throw for 69% you know like screw
69% you got players you got people there
yep yards to be had let it loose let it
go
yes schirmer's offense those crossers
they're so vital to what they do and it
is always a great formula it's something
that's really I think more offenses
should call those type of plays more
like we were just talking about but New
England they kind of do this what Stefon
Diggs and feel exactly right right
that's all I thought about too and I'm
watching the game I'm like this is what
the Elenin digs it all year last year
but yeah the point about the red zone
yeah they can't rely on Eli they're a
little bit like the Falcons last year
they have to find a war from 4000
Delavan Coleman they're in a box right
that's not there because he's just not
the kind of guy that's gonna buy a whole
out of time and he's not gonna throw
rifles into the back of the end zone and
we're gonna be a wall he fitted in there
but Odell ever yeah I mean I think
that's what they'll have to do or they
gonna have to find creative screens with
the receivers or a sake wand so that the
key that we're not talking about is we
got one playoffs a fine-ass preseason
yeah if say we don't we have very high
hopes for sake watch mmm we have no idea
how he's gonna be no we don't but in the
end down the red zone that's what we're
gonna learn yeah I would think that yes
they're gonna
call off your it's not the answer no he
is not I almost don't think he should
make the team I mean he's definitely on
our quo yeah I would agree I would agree
I think it's about over four jonatha
stories been awesome he's an NFL legend
but yeah he's he's to that age where
it's just there's no explosion Raiders
Packers first play deep post two Amari
Cooper I agree he looked great man he
has he's another one of those guys
really great in 50/50 balls yes he's
like his specialty where's he gonna go
on fantasy draft he's going a lot in
fantasy drafts towards the middle end of
the third round Wow
so that's probably in around like what
37 where the really good receivers
usually go
Antonio's going top-five Odell's going
top seven eight with DeAndre Hopkins is
going top seven eight
Odell is going top ten 11 with Michael
Thomas Keenan Allen then Davante Adams
is that middle group of the second round
with AJ Green I think they don't get
Mike Evans then on the way back you're
getting like the T Y Hilton's Larry
Fitzgerald's a now Marty Cooper needs to
be in that I'm just from my firm I to
sense Gruden it calling him his main
vein that's what I mean Gruden's gonna
I'm telling you everything they do in
the past games gonna be around Amari
Cooper if I know Jon Gruden but he would
be a guy where I'm not saying he's a
Antonio Dell I'll tell you the problem
though yeah as someone who's had an MRI
Cooper on their team for multiple years
he can just disappear well he'd only did
this last year the other years before
that he was pretty consistent I don't
know he'll have some game last year was
horrible but it wasn't all him he had
dropped certainly Derek Carr was hurt
you wrote the Raiders tackles or the big
question yeah interior three are special
but the two tackles are quote barely
hanging on yeah so that's Donald Penn
and Colton Miller you're a Colt Miller
looks good I'm worried about his pen I
saw Colton Miller get destroyed a few
times by the packer he does I mean he
does every week he's it's the same thing
in college a little bit as why I wasn't
in love with him and I do think he B's
over drafted because it was a light
draft in tackles in general so he ended
up being a mid first rounder and yes I
don't think he was only what was he
seven or eight spots behind a McGlinchey
I want to go like no he should have been
like 30 spots behind him--as glyn chi
but yes he does scare me at that
position especially in year one he's got
a Nate's older body he certainly has the
body to be something but his ability to
anchor in there in in against a power
rush is scary and he just does not have
great bend in his hips to where he can
really just squat down and get his body
he kind of leans with his outside how
was Donald Donald open okay
it wasn't great he got caught on skates
a few times where he got caught in bad
positions got pushed back into the
quarterback but yeah there they got a
catch up to the interior line because
that's the special interior line hackers
defense did look special
Reggie Gilbert popping again yeah
Mohammed Wilkerson you wrote looks like
his old form Josh Jackson and J year you
wrote both have great ball skills chai
ear on the pick was phenomenal
phenomenal kind of undercutting the wide
receiver getting underneath yeah but you
wrote it's all gonna come down to three
guys can Wilkerson Kenny Clark and Mike
Daniel stay healthy yeah and if they
don't I think they're in trouble that
defense because I think so much of what
they do is gonna be predicated on their
ability to control those AB&C gaps
upfront and their you know those three
together if you get the Mohammad
Wilkerson that we saw two years ago with
the Jets and things like that yeah
they'll be they'll be immovable because
Mike Daniels is one of the best interior
Dean linemen in football and then Kenny
Clark is good and Mohammed could be
special and he can really clog things up
and do a lot of different things for
your D line but yeah I just look at
their their middle linebackers like you
and I talked about where it's not great
and I think they're gonna have to put a
lot of pressure on those guys to stop
the run by themselves a lot of the time
I am NOT gonna do another podcast
without talking about the Raiders young
defensive linemen it's doing a
disservice because Raiders fans hit us
up all the time and to be honest
ardan key Maurice Hurst PJ high and this
kid for dole Brown yeah every time I
watch Raiders games they're popping off
the screen yes they are I mean the art
and key things all realize this they
took PJ Hall in the second round of this
trade he's the balls the one from Sam
Houston State he's six foot 308 pounds
then in the third round they come back
and they take art and key the freak
athlete LSU yes and the fifth round get
Maurice Hirst that a lot of people
thought he was gonna go earlier in the
traffic but he had some medical yes
right this fado Brown I just opened up
his profile he was a guy yeah I don't he
was a free agent that was from
Mississippi that I don't think got
drafted last you know he did not and
this is their second their second line
yes they look bigger than everyone they
play well yes now am i overhyping them
they're not big guys though so don't
think that Louise Hurst is about these
six one to ninety-two right that's what
I mean they're not that way it looks so
big it's part of the Raiders uniform
that's why either the Raiders look scary
when they're walking on the field I mean
I truly do believe that to a degree yes
they have sounded like an extra in
departed cranberry juice okay so they
actually looked bigger than they
actually are
yes but still first look six five I know
and he's not and it's funny because if
you saw him in Michigan in uniform you'd
go oh yeah he doesn't look that big are
didn't key I I guess I you know I wasn't
in love with him in the drought I was
like I don't know he's got but I
obviously got him wrong with these LSU
pass rushers or yes those those type of
guys but they're gonna contribute
certainly Hurst can be a disrupter he's
not gonna be a guy that holds like the
gap and takes on double teams he could
be more of that Geno Atkins can beat you
feed three tech news spit move in that
game that was unbelievably know I know
yeah I think god I miss evaluated him in
the draft he's better than what I
thought to this point certainly happens
yeah they also signed DRC which I think
they definitely needed there but I did
the Raiders are interesting but I
definitely agree with you their tackles
look scary yes very scary let's move on
let's not just don't forget to of the
Raiders they've been lucky Dan they
really like haven't had to play a lot of
starting offensive linemen either yet
right
Packers were playing a lot of backup
right the Rams the week before played
nobody okay so you're seeing J hall and
them know they still been phenomenal
there's no doubt about it but just to
remember that like some of those guys
are seeing like third stringers when
they're getting to go in there
the Packers is going in he's going to
get see the starters
Reggie Gilbert reminds me who was the
Detroit lineman that a carry hider Kenny
yeah carry hider just like like oh it's
just pre-season and then he had like
seven sacks in seven weeks
like that's what I'm seeing with Reggie
Gilbert he they really haven't had a guy
like him in a while no they have not and
it's good because Clay Matthews is not
the the great pass rusher we once know
Nick Perry is really their guy but this
will give them another guy yeah that
they can add in the rotation Steelers
Titans yeah you wrote Big Bend looks
phenomenal phenomenal and so pure right
what are we gonna see at a Big Bend this
year big year I really like what I saw
from the Steelers in general the
Steelers have changed my mind in the
last two weeks like I thought maybe it
was like man are they gonna be like a
little hangover like we should have won
the Super Bowl last year and we screwed
it up ourselves but man I mean Big Ben
just comes in the game and just doesn't
miss a beat
I mean you know pure pure every ball
that came out of his hand was pure I
mean looks different with how skinny he
does he's quicker yeah yeah yeah I mean
he does his feet are poppin as he's
going through his reads instead of the
old Ben who just would like you know
again I'm gonna stand up one more time
where he would just stand there
flat-footed and go through reads and be
like nope he's not open nope he's not
open let me know I'm ready now a little
bounce
a little bounce exactly right so you're
expecting a big year I am I am
definitely we'll find out how people
find out how big and their defense all
right let's get to that side the ball
one guy is really impressing you Matthew
Thomas settling in at middle linebacker
which I guess was Shea's ears role
they're playing a little bit an early
nickel right he wrote later on your
notes you wrote I like Thomas yes you
underlined it and then you gave it a
double star yeah because thick it is it
is I think I double start it because
okay right now they got Vince Williams
and was this Mathew Tom and John and
John Bostick I don't know a lot about
him he was somebody that was late he's
out of Miami later guy I didn't study
him coming out in the draft you know me
cuz I'm only really just
Beauford like the furnace was a free
agent at a florida state part of state
sorry I said Miami but yeah I don't know
nothing and much about him other than
what I've seen really this preseason and
I saw him last week and I said no this
kid looks pretty good and then this week
yeah he got in there with the ones again
and then anytime you get in there in the
ones I don't care what capacity you're
going in on the ones
I'm gonna go damn who are you and what
are you doing because the coach values
you at that point it's not like they're
just throwing you in their preseason
game number one like oh you know this is
preseason game three Stefan to its of
the world we're out there debug Dupri's
Joe Hayden was out there and who this
Thomas kid and I just look at that
position for that defense we know how
important it is Vince Williams is a
really good football player
Bostick is good and can fill the role I
think for the Smash Mouth part but he's
a liability in passing situations so do
you believe that Matthew Thomas is the
shazier replacement for the steel I
think like Vince still takes that for
now Vince Williams but I think as this
goes you're gonna see Vince and this
Thomas kid on the field a whole lot if
they want to do blitzberg and do some of
these crazy things they need a guy that
can run and go oh you're responsible for
this backside a gap but when the ball is
outside to the the left side there we
also need you to be fast enough to go
out there make the tests there any
chance that they go the three safety set
with Sean Davis Morgan Burnett and and
Terrell Edmonds they could and put
Terrell Edmonds at middle line right
right they could they could do that or
even a Morgan Burnett could do that
the thing that Terrell Edmonds has I
think he's got special coverage ability
that's where it's like I don't want to
risk him in the Box too much because his
range you saw the interception he had
right the way he got off yeah and ran
down the field and firstly that was
stupid by Mariota tackled him with his
right shoulder in his thigh like I'm
like come on man let's get to that
finish but yes the Furion the Steelers D
was they've changed their back 7 ok
break this down you know because years
of we gone they're just not athletic
enough back there there's not enough
players Joe Hayden looks very good
already Byrnes is what you're
really special athlete Sean Davis super
a super athlete again year three so it's
no longer just kid running around like a
chicken with his head cut off
remember that's an athlete Morgan
Burnett's an athlete with a little more
side edmonds right and then let's not
forget that Stefan - it played the whole
year with a torn bicep tendon last year
and Stefan - it's the best player on
this defense when healthy and man did he
whoop the crap out of the Titans
interior lion when he was in there you
wrote that you wrote the Titans interior
offense is a little scary it is a little
scary so if you flipped the Titans and
the Raiders and combined them and put
Conklin and Lewan with the Raiders
interior it's the perfect aligned yeah
but you're a little bit worried about
the interior of the Titans line and I
would imagine in a Matt Lafleur offense
which is rooted in a Shanahan offense
guards are very important very important
and it's that's scary I'd rather have I
think good interior I'd rather have the
Raiders problem than their problem yeah
because you can hide the tackle is you
can help Beck's chipping tight end over
their shoulder center exactly right and
if there's two good defensive tackles
you know good luck trying to help them
then and and that's kind of what
happened to them it's it's it's Hayward
it's to it okay yeah there's no help bud
Dupree is on the edge - well yeah their
interior offensive line is Quinton Spain
Ben Jones and Josh Klein and they
started with them for them the whole
year like yeah they did I know and it
just has not been very impressive to
this point
Dennis Kelly's in there right now
because Conklin still hurt right so I
don't know how that's gonna I don't know
either
right but it did that was not what
jumped out to me it was more or less
just those interior guys they really
struggle in the game and also Mariota oh
my god you wrote Mariota is throwing is
a little concerning to me it's a trend
so far in the preseason it just doesn't
look good it's affecting his
decision-making yeah I do I think it's
affect I think there was a few throws
early on where he saw the guy he just
said I don't trust myself throwing this
I'm gonna check it down to throw an
easier one but some of the throws I
don't know how much you saw on
highlights or whatever it may be I wrote
this last week right we brought this up
last week I can't remember who the hell
they played the preseason game last week
but I there was a few throws in that
game where I was just like damn
like it's okay to be off target but they
were way off target and I didn't like
the look of some of the completions and
things like I said he yes
he's he just not thrown the ball well
again he gets no opposites he creates no
torque with his upper body
he gets a totally still front body now
you're seeing a trend I am and and then
he realizes he does it and he'll try to
change his most motion like he had a
throw to Corey Davis on his right side
where Corey Davis is running across the
middle of the field and he's wide open
and it's like he thought about oh let me
do what I've been trying to work on and
practice or whatever and he tried to
change his motion mitt throw ball went
like 10 feet over Corey Davis his head
he's wide open for a 20-yard gain went
way over his head yeah it's a little
concerned about the Titans I'm concerned
about him right now now they have enough
good players and they hopefully they can
have a run game that they can lean on
but yeah they're there that's a little
confident you and Derrick Henry this
year like mmm the Titans are so tough
for me are you more confident in Dion
Lewis than Derrick Henry no I'm still
gonna go with Henry is my guy I think
you still think he's gonna wear people's
asses out as the game goes on I'm still
trying to get a fantasy nuggets for
people that's what I'm doing no thank
you
Saints Chargers you wrote that the
Saints aligned had their hands full with
the Chargers d-line and you wrote that
Marcus Davenport's out there he's long
and rangy and the Saints need him they
need another stone on the front seven
yeah doesn't look all that explosive but
strong reckless physical and
recklessness Akala t just doesn't care
about his body or anybody else's body
he's if you're in his way and you're
supposed to be tackled he's gonna dive
like Superman and put his face and body
in harm's way and he doesn't care I
always loved that about any guy like
that it's like Jadeveon Clowney that's
what we always loved about him he gets
around the edge a few times in the game
and I just he's such a long Strider it
doesn't always look pretty but yet the
Saints have a lot of good in that front
seven we know they only have one stud
and that's our man candy Jordan right
Sheldon Rankin's is good I'm in yata
I've always best up all the
they're all good players Manti Te'o and
them in the middle is good but yeah they
need another guy don't know I'm not
concerned but I just think if they want
to be Super Bowl win the Super Bowl they
need to they need another threat on that
front seven that teams are gonna have to
worry about in game plan so I'm just
saying they need him to get out there
and start producing they traded away
assets for him because they're in win
mode now and he's been dealing would
they believe a groin injury right so
they need him to start contributing if
they want to kind of get with you show
you enough that when he can be the guy
yeah yeah definitely
yes so you believe that they have him
and cam Jordan they'll be good there'll
be a there'll be a handful yes they will
be on the other side Chargers you you
identified kazeer white started at
middle linebacker looks good really fast
yes who's this kid cuz you're white as a
kid at of West Virginia long I'm gonna
say he's like six to maybe two 30 ish
somewhere in there are you pulling them
up yep
yeah Durrant J Ron Brown or jarama
thrown picked this year right jeté vez
Browns the one on the charger Chavis
Brown is the one on the charge of 1862
to 1800 he's lighter than I thought he
doesn't look that light but yes he did
pop on film you know next there to
Denzel parameter extremely physical and
for a rookie the thing I was really
impressed with his ability to read him
react like when he saw a play he shot
his gun I mean if he oh there's the hole
they're gonna run through it I'm not
gonna wait for them to come to me and
somebody block me or I let the running
back run over I'm gonna get up in that
hole and make things disruptive right
away yeah and I do think he's gonna be
if they start him like they need a
middle linebacker like that in the pass
game they need him they need a guy
that's got a little range and speed you
know the other guys are a little under
sized and kind of those compact type
middle linebackers Chargers and Saints
two teams I know that you're thinking
about putting them in the super plan now
did either of them validate themselves
more to you or did either them hurt
themselves for you no I don't think in
either one I don't think either one
impressive just as a roster yeah I mean
the this preseason the Chargers have
played more impressively to me just
their overall play
Sean Payton didn't play a lot of guys
you know Drew Brees has only played
spotty here and there I do think that's
secondary you know for this the Saints
is gonna be damn good Pat you know let's
not forget your man Patrick Robinson
they're down a nickel now he said you
got him and crawly and Lattimore that's
a pretty good cover three right there
yeah I mean I think the Saints both of
these teams are gonna be in the mix of
things I just would be shocked mm-hmm we
haven't even seen like the forest lamps
contribute right that's where I like I
turn on the Chargers every week and I go
ooh let me see what the new old line
looks like oh they're opening up some
holes maybe they have some other guys in
there nope it's the same ones they're
just they're playing really well I mean
bouncy youth center has been a great
addition has he
he has been you could tell right away
without a doubt I mean they they're
opening up holes on all parts of the
offensive line bar sales go to right
tackle and that really excites me when I
think more about the Chargers is you
have this Anthony Lin team yeah that you
know he wants to be rooted in attacking
defense and like pounding offense and
then the fact that you have this coach
on the field and rivers that if they
need to go to minute yeah he can run an
offense by himself but the integrity of
the offensive line is still gonna always
be downhill yeah and I just think when
you have a Pouncy at center it makes
everybody nasty or - I would agree
there's just not a lot of centers that
are that athletic in the NFL right
Melvin Gordon I think is my guy to have
a huge eii I wouldn't be shocked that's
sort of a contract here yes and he
didn't play the other day they're saving
his but he'll be ready to go they'll be
ready to go Broncos Washington is where
we're gonna finish right here
first thing is you talked about guys
getting run with the once Troya key ooh
he fast
oh he fast fast yeah the white kid from
Penn State that ran the fast 40 right
ran him with the ones with Washington
yes he's on Washington yeah
Sid he has tremendous range he did miss
a tackle but his speed translate right
it's kind of gonna be like a real NFL
player I think he is first time he was
on the field I said who is his 30 kid
because the first play was the go route
down the left sideline Emmanuel Sanders
caught it if you remembered keen him
through a nice ball diving and the
safety almost got there and it was
almost a big collision he kind of
tripped and fell out of balance and I
said damn that guy covered a lot of
grass
I was like man 30 you white guy I was a
cold wait is that the app key kid and I
turned it on yes he has tremendous range
that's where I think he'll first get on
the field like if they want to do those
three safety looks and they want speed
in the back end he's your guy not not
you know swear injure or montane nickels
yes that's not the guys you want back
there this is the perfect guy for that
yeah the next thing we need to see is in
the box breaking down like yeah Emmanuel
Sanders he should have made that tackle
on the reverse he breaks the tackle and
scores a touchdown shout-out to Matt
Bowen white safety that we got to oh
that's right what all that Bowen at bow
and I believe it's picked off Tom Brady
and Michael the holiday I'm happy to
Gary yes he did I love Matt yay one guy
that you were a little down on by I
think came back and impressed she was
Bradley Chubb yeah you said he's look
best chubbers looked was in this came
and you also wrote second play of the
game he is playing stand-up will
linebacker that says something I didn't
know what it said so I would like you to
tell me what does that mean to you when
you see the second play of the game he's
standing up at line but it meant two
things that he's obviously smart and
versatile to where they said you know we
can change your position you've never
played myth stand up linebacker in your
life in a 4-3 scheme and we've never
seen you do it at NC State but we're
concurring and the mentality you have at
this point
concurrent career would you concur and
you're encouraged so where it means
we're all agreement and we're encouraged
he's all over my English and also yeah I
found it a hair also so that was the
positive side but I also look at it in a
negative side and go damn this the fifth
pick of the draft and we're moving his
position why hasn't he playing for 3d
Vincennes isn't that why we drafted him
hmm so there's the double there that's
all I'm saying just you don't know what
it means I don't know either I'm just
giving you both but food for thought but
either way like you and I talked about
last week with him is we we haven't seen
that explosion I saw a few snaps of this
game where I felt like he to let it go
like he just was like yeah he got after
it a twist a stunt and I just said damn
there's the guy that's kicking into the
next gear you also wrote you've been
very impressed with Justin Simmons he
was of course the safety was the reason
they fell okay letting go
TJ Ward last year but I always love when
you write things like this is the
Washington offense could it be dink and
dunk I don't know what it's gonna be but
I am NOT excited about it no I am NOT I
just the way the first is imagine you'd
be like I don't like this yeah it's just
nothing to hang your hat on to this
point it has nothing been nothing
special they do have potential but you
know I always worry about the Alex Smith
factor and that offense lends itself to
short throws too i won I believe that
Washington is going to have a better
year this year than last year right I
think that I want this team to be really
good the d-line is young but it excites
me Alex Smith moving in the pocket yeah
made me get excited when I thought about
Jameson Crowder in the middle Chris
Thompson the two tight ends I'm most
excited I hear that because with Jordan
Reed and a guy that vert is played with
and Vernon Davis that core for I'm not
even getting at the outside of Paul
Richardson - Josh Thaksin right the
options that they could do with those
guys
I just don't know Jay Gruden's offense
enough to know it needs to be a little
Philadelphia Eagle II it needs to be a
little Frank Wright like here's another
I'm just giving away sleepers at this
point I think Eric Ebron is a sleeper
because I think that a lot of people
know jack Doyle but Frank Wright is
gonna have two tight ends on the field
all the time when he brought is so much
more athletic than than oil right but I
look at that offense with Washington I
go man if it's Thompson Jameson with
those two tight ends now we're getting
this on yes but I don't know I know it's
scary just from that but I boom
everything you're saying man I mean I
think you're spot on we haven't seen
Jordan Reed out there yet we haven't
seen Jameson Crowder out there yet
so they're there laying in the weeds -
we might not see what they are gonna be
really Jay might be taking I got some
Alex Smith tricks up my sleeve for week
one I'm gonna say this right now when
I'm predicting games right for week one
yeah I'm gonna look at the roster I need
to figure out all the injury reports and
the suspensions but I am blacking out
everything from preseason because that's
what screwed me last yeah I remember
it's about looking at the guys and
seeing it not looking
they've been right it's like bills
yesterday yeah I remove that for my
brain yeah that was awful I don't think
I shouldn't remove it that one might be
who they are that it is I don't think
you should Rajesh Allen has the toughest
road ahead of him
you know I sent you that picture of the
schedule yeah
if Josh Allen starts he might be dead by
October I mean it's scary their first
four games are at Baltimore home against
the Chargers with the the program yeah
Joey Bo said Melvin Ingram at Minnesota
with that defense of an at Green Bay
holy crap I know and survived out of all
the rookie quarterbacks he has the least
talent around him as receivers and tight
ends and I would say gosh yeah it's just
it's the mere probably the worst
offensive line out of all the rookies
too I mean really it's yeah right I mean
it's them are Arizona man so yeah he's
it's gonna be tough it's gonna be
interesting to see what they do with
some of these quarterback decisions
because I am one that you know I think
the young guys should play get them out
there get going but are they gonna be
some of these head coaches gonna be
worried about the state of their
football team and where they're at right
now and be reluctant to throw these guys
in there I have a few fan questions and
we're gonna wrap up first one is Todd
lip countdown Charlotte is Khalil Mack
not getting a deal with the Raiders a
classic move by Cruden or does Reggie
McKenzie really not want to pay him I
think it's got to be a regimen Kenzi
Mark Davis thing I don't think this is a
John Gurdon thing I really don't I would
be shocked that if I saw a whole
storyline about how he's like
indifferent yeah I'm sure he is like I'm
sure he doesn't want them to give them
so much money that he can't sign free
agent often suppliers experience that
Odell gets a deal Aaron Donald is really
close and Khalil Mack is not even
talking and talking to him no I know I
know and it sounds like the trade stuff
is still pretty real with Coyle like
it's it's a possibility I still would be
surprised if it happens yeah and I think
the Raiders are pretty dumb if they do
that but yeah it doesn't sound like
they're anywhere close Steelers nation
84 you've definitely told this story
before on the podcast you know if it
tell the whole thing but we do have new
listeners did Sims ever see Matthew
McConaughey at practice or side
during a game at Texas all right all
right all right source I did of course I
did I mean he used to stand next to me
while I was warming up for games and
like talk to me in my ear and I went to
adamm I'm kind of trying to think about
a game right now would you get away from
me like well he'd be like yeah Sims yeah
look good today
you know you'd say like this always
pumping you always pumping me up I mean
he's one of the richest guys in the city
Austin and he would come and come do the
games of the cutoff t-shirt cutoff
sleeves and cargo shorts that were cargo
pants at one time that he decided just
to cut there manually maymay really made
cargo shorts with a huge ink stain on
his right thigh and he wore them almost
like nine out of ten every ten times I
saw him and you would you ever call him
I'll be like yo you're gonna get a new
pair of shoes you know I never did I
asked them things like what did like J
Lo's butt look like and like some of
those movies and things like back to
that he laughed at me my best moments of
Matthew McConaughey's yet vendrick is
the best moments were Thursday practices
when he would be in town or show up
because Thursday practices like the NFL
Friday practice is easy right it's kind
of like it's it's a little more than a
walkthrough but it's not too serious he
he would warm up with me and he run
around like he was a kid he'd be like
running on the side of UK sim stuff
throw it do you like throw his hand out
I throw him a ball he throw it back but
no won't good hands
he did he did he's a good little athlete
got a little muscle definition as you've
seen but then we'd start practice and
I'd get out there on the field and well
we would practice he would work out and
he would run around the field I think
I've told you this where he would take
his shirt off run around the field and
then at every corner of the endzone
it was either a like a push-up station
or a sit-up station and he would just do
that and really work up a lather and
like legit workout but man he was the
man for like two three hours so just be
running into it pushing he was doing
those practices probably about an hour
and 30 minutes but yeah he would go I
would say about an hour and I think wow
he's he was right the team down oh yeah
he was not allowed around the team for a
while remember when he got caught naked
with the bongos and a huge thing of weed
in his
right Harrelson was there it's something
like that and like the neighbor called
because they said it was too loud sounds
like Fenric on the two so you know
that's usually what Fender does we know
that but he wasn't he was barred from
the team from Mack Brown said listen
you're playing a bongo you said hello
crazy don't make a setup like we didn't
see him for a year and then he got back
in the good graces and he was back again
and then what kind of speeches would he
give uh they had to be better than other
people
well yeah it was really likes the team
knows football so passionate just yeah
it was always cool you know funny joke
you know and then the importance of like
Texas football and even like how
important it was to him and he was
excited to watch us play on Saturday and
he couldn't wait like he was he was
great What did he say to you after the
Oklahoma games yeah and I never saw him
never saw him he was like who's the
other guy in the back car of Good Will
Hunting
you know Good Will Hunting right poor
guys it was Ben it's Casey Affleck the
other guy the guy with the red curly
hair right he was man that was like
anyone's map the guy the head he had
like a really deep we're gonna put you a
bigger I know that yes he was on the
sidelines for a game once right
yes why is he not on here it was cole
hauser cold how it is cold you're right
yes
Cole would he was on the sidelines for
our Texas A&M game Cole plays a good
villain and like TV drum right right oh
yes or like the cool like Southie
gangster like it was in Google but he
was there with him for a Texas A&M game
and I I tore it up pretty good and that
was cool coming off the sidelines and
having them like being like the first
one to greet me after I threw a
touchdown and then like slapping me five
and slapped me on the ass we need to get
Matthew McConaughey on the show we
should be doing time we do last one sly
boy underscore 22 after re-watching the
Raiders backup quarterbacks
Connor cookie Jay Manuel de Sims have
any interest and coming back and playing
another year for good yeah yeah
gosh that's another team that I do this
is a trade for RG the back up situation
is a little concerning
I think EJ I knew I should do it I I'm
not going back to play
I thought Jon Gruden said counter cook
was a first-round pick that's what he
told me last time and he's not when you
watch guys though in pre-season like
week three and four do you go man if I
trained like six months I know I don't
do that I look at some of these guys and
go this freaking guys in the NFL are you
[ __ ] kidding me that's what I want to
say is if somebody you don't go man if I
really if I stopped working with Lefko
and I I pledge my setups at the corner
of the field it's been out of that mode
for a long time now the first two or
three years I was out of the league I
was looking at people on Sundays and
like it was like damn are you kidding me
you couldn't shine my shoes when I was
but I was healthy okay up with Josh's
trainer we'll work on your lower body
yeah those cat those calf definitions
okay so Sims has given us some sleepers
vendrick I'm gonna say this right now
and we're gonna see what happens I
think's French Eric and I are going to
the new Dan and John sports bar New York
tomorrow to do our draft check out
Instagram at Sims and left coat we're
gonna do some of our picks we're gonna
FaceTime Chris we'll get some of his
reactions to our players the incredibly
named Odell Rogers
it's gonna be really really good Oh Dale
Rogers someone just tweeted and they
said if Simms doesn't say Odell
Beckham's the greatest wide receiver in
the league he'll be disappointed so
Odell Beckham jr. is the greatest
receiver I've ever seen again
congratulations to David walleston the
winner of the Odell Beckham attract
we're gonna get your information we're
gonna send you some gear you are awesome
now we're just waiting on Aaron Donald
and Khalil Matt wants some gear and
mhmmm not gonna you got kind of that
little weird bump of the front we don't
want to make the brand look bad as
always Simza left go on social and then
Wednesday is our big preview josh is
going to moderate we're gonna do all the
divisions we are gonna do the winners of
the Super Bowl
you know it's 95 out today right you're
gonna take this off I just want I told
what hey I wanted to be comfortable yeah
I didn't want to wear a t-shirt that
made me look like I was doing comedy act
in an
and an aluminum factory for sim seats
out homie fedra could say good evening
and the lef koe and says holla holla
O'Dell congratulations man you deserve
that you are the best wide receiver in
the league will be back on wins to do it
to oil